oh my god is he actually is that his
real
oh
hi
everybody this is nadia
hi yep i've heard so much about this
people asking me if i'd seen it trying
to watch the entirety of daniel green's
most controversial video um
which is his book cleaning video because
apparently it's just
wildly
difficult to get through and as a
conscientious booktuber i feel like it's
my duty
my duty to watch the entirety of this
video are you ready i feel like you have
more of a stomach for like violence done
to books than i do i do watch dateline a
lot
all right let's watch this thing ready
okay let's do it all right
okay so any booktube video that starts
in the bathroom is immediately suspect
maybe he just pooped
yeah that's why it's suspect
and he just keeps the lapel mic on his
shirt at all times just in case for
content
just like he's holding it oh my god
nice shower really make sure yeah okay
okay this is worse than you like okay
i'm just wondering what like we're at
the
three minute mark oh my god what more
can he do to the book
and now do you say floppy toppy
this is partly shower ass
yeah it's a nice shower yeah oh my god
is he actually is that his real please
say that he won't like brush his teeth
afterwards
he literally started
this in the bathroom it's probably poopy
maybe he's going through something
maybe i can try to empathize yeah we
shouldn't
take your favorite deodorant now what
you're going to do with this deodorant
is really just finding the clothes okay
this is not going to happen
okay
pips can't even look at it
i mean i thought it was going to be
worse okay so daniel green says i can't
i can't have books stacked sideways on a
bookshelf yet he does that nevertheless
the video is an abomination it is a
stain on
the booktube community
who hurt you hurt people hurt books
okay
[Music]